I would love to ask you what are your
opening problems let's take it from
there okay please please right well the
best move order because okay let's go
backwards and forwards okay so II for is
by far the most common classical opening
moves
efore and E 5 as long had the reputation
of being the move that black uses to
fight for equality right out of the
opening so II 45 now what had happened
to me is that when my opponents played
Knight f3
I played Knight f6 and I went into so
what we call the Petroff defense what
the rest of the world really refers to
is the Russian defense and I was a happy
camper so one day I came up against this
very tricky Grandmaster from Yugoslavia
Luba merely boyish and Lubo played d4 so
I always and I admired him greatly for
this this actually happened at the board
I had no real choice I took the pawn and
now he played Knight f3 so in this is AK
position I have a wealth of moves a
large number of moves and I sat for the
better part of 30 minutes going through
all the moves that I could potentially
play in this position so the first move
for example was c5 I'm upon up
got it upon it but after c3d takes c3
Knight takes c3 I hated my position I
just considered that this is an
excellent excellent pawn sacrifice for
white whites whites play is so easy
he simply brings his Bishop to c4 he
castles if I ever put my pawn on d6
he'll bring his Bishop to f4 he'll nail
it and black is just simply much much
much worse my second thought was Bishop
b4 check and when I was a kid I
absolutely absolutely loved the Danish
gambit and I played things like the
Evans gambit with b4 on move three and
so forth and so on and after Bishop b4
check see 3d takes c3 B takes c3
regardless of where I move my bishop
Bishop a5 Bishop c5 Bishop e7 comes
Bishop c4 and I'm worse I hated my
position I really did
so after Knight f3 here I thought well
if I go Knight f6 I'm now in a line of
the Russian defense that I'm trying to
avoid so he would play e5 Knight here
Queen takes this the all of these moves
have been played countless hundreds of
games and it's well known that after
Queen oops excuse me Queen f4 check this
is a position that favors white White's
play again is very simple White's plan
is to play Bishop e3 castles long and
White's plan is to play Knight d5 so in
other words this was a very tricky move
order that got me out of my Russian
defense let's go back for a second
I play the move Knight most people play
the move Knight f3
I play the move Knight f6
now if they play the move d4 I don't
take the pawn which would get me into
the position that I had with Lu Bo I
would take the pawn on e4 and this is
the position that I wanted to play with
the Russian defense so in other words
white if White's intent shin is to play
the Scotch you should do it with the
move d4 so after d4 takes Knight f3
after a long thing I said a half-an-hour
I played knight c6 in other words I
thought that after going through all the
possibilities oh pardon me there was one
other possibility after Knight f3 the
other possibility was d5 to avoid the
Scotch but this kind of looks a little
bit like the Scandinavian after takes
takes Knight here I didn't like this
position because unlike in the
Scandinavian where for example I could
go Queen a5 well after Knight takes d4
it's very clear that my queen is not a
happy camper
so d4 takes Knight f3 if somebody is
intent on playing the Scotch against you
you play knight c6 okay now here you
could your opponents of white can
consider moves Bishop c4 they can
consider mu c3 but if they're going to
play the Scotch they're going to play
Knight takes d4 now you're in it
now you're in it Knight takes d4 so here
after pretty much some thought
I played Knight f6 and we went into a
mainline scotch and okay I won with
black but the Scotch today requires a
great deal of
knowledge okay one of the old and
favorite moves of Steinitz was Queen h4
okay I don't like this move I think that
this move is too dangerous for black the
idea was that after Knight b5 Queen
takes e4 Czech Bishop e2 in view of the
threat of night take c7 you play King d8
you defend a c7 square after the move
castles I think black is supposed to
play a six-night c3 Queen e8 Knight d5
and it's a very funny thing at the end
of the day you know like if you were
walking by the playing hall or something
walking by the board you would say you
know the idiots are playing a
scholastics tournament they start they
set up the king and the Queen on the
wrong squares and you know guys I'm
going to have to stop the clock and
reset the pieces because this is not the
way it's supposed to go
but Steinitz would like to defend this
position upon down and I don't like it
so we go back to this position but black
actually has three major moves outside
of Queen h4 the most popular is Knight
f6 going into the standard scotch
the second most popular is Bishop c5 so
the most popular line of the Scotch goes
Knight f6 Knight takes c6 takes e5 Queen
e7 Queen e2 Knight d5 c4 bishop a6
hundreds of hundreds of games thousands
of games huge number of variations here
for white white could play b3 with the
idea of Bishop a3 why can play g3 as
Gary Kasparov played on a number of
occasions against Gary Anatoly Karpov in
their 1990 World Championship match
crazy move h4 what's the idea of h4 the
idea of H
four is after the move castles you go
rook here what's the idea of rook h3
well the bishop on a six attacks the
Queen on e two x-rays I should say the
Queen on e 2 so you can't take this
Knight
so the idea of rook h3 is to go rook a3
attack the bishop
if the bishop gets defended by the King
well then you simply take the bishop and
take the knight meanwhile other ideas
include Bishop g5 and so on there are a
ton of lines Nigel short in his 1993
World Championship match with Garry
Kasparov preferred Bishop c5 and after
Bishop c5 Knight takes Queen f6
threatening made on f2 provoked the move
Queen d2 takes on I think by me takes on
c6 Knight c3 and again massive amount of
complications very unbalanced position
very very hard to play because it just
takes so much knowledge and so much time
to understand and learn the line so I
had a long discussion with a dear friend
now departed Anthony miles Tony miles
and he was saying you know like he loved
the dragon Sicilian but the guys were
now lining up to crush his dragon
Sicilian by preparing to move 100 so he
was going to make the switch to a
classical defense
efore a5 and he wanted to pull the game
into a particular line of the rulli
Lopez is black and he really didn't mind
the Kings gambit he was ready to handle
the Kings gambit his problem was the
Scotch so I said to him
Tony when you look at the Scotch as
white it's almost kind of a gambit style
play obviously White has not made a
gambit but it's very simple what white
wants to do white wants to develop his
Knight to c3 he wants to play his Bishop
to c4 he wants to castles and it's all
about fast fast fast fast development
okay clear
I said you can screw up White's
development he said well how do I do
that I say well what's the most natural
square for the knight on b1 he says of
course c3 I said okay what you do is you
go Bishop b4 check then he goes okay
well what does that do I said well if
the guy plays Knight c3 now after the
move Knight f6 white is screwed up he
can't play this Knight takes c3 B takes
c6 ePHI Queen e7 line Queen e2 line
because the first and foremost is when
the queen is on e2 it's blocking the
bishop on f8 which provokes black into
this whole line where he castles long
now after Knight d5 there's no c4 this
is simply a good position for black
after Bishop d2 you Castle short White's
King is in the center black is doing
great move Knight c3 sucks
clearly he says so you have to play c3
only move for an advantage new memo okay
I say now you messed white up now he
stuck his pawn on c3 which is the ideal
Square for his knight now you play
Bishop c5 now you play Bishop c5
according to the books the best move for
white is Bishop e3 you play Bishop d6
now it doesn't really matter what white
places next few moves can be
interchangeable he could play Bishop c4
or 92 and it doesn't matter after for
example Bishop let's say 92 you go 97
the guy goes Bishop c4 you go castles he
goes castles with his knight on D 2
instead of its best Square C 3 what does
white give up he gives up control over
the d5 square d 5 takes Knight takes
black equalizes very easily okay but if
you don't know this Bishop b4 check idea
you can run into a lot of problems
especially against a player who's really
very well prepared and the scotch game
strangely enough it was Garry Kasparov
who really took the century old the
oldest oldest oldest line of play and
really revitalized it with a lot of new
ideas essentially one thing kept his
World Championship title thanks to the
Scotch defense it was only that after
Tony miles actually started playing
Bishop before our check in numerous
games that the Scotch suddenly wasn't
winning all of the games that and did
and you weren't getting those imbalance
oops you weren't getting those imbalance
positions that the white player is
trying to meet so Ken considering that
we would that we imagine that you're
black in this moment and you know you
you obviously play against the
opponent's you play with what would you
imagine that one of your opponent's
might play in this position if is why
would they just develop their Bishop to
e3 because that looks like a good move
yeah Bishop c4 one way one one of it
they actually think that Bishop III is a
little bit more accurate just to induce
this loss of the tempo but it doesn't
matter we'll play Bishop c4 as you like
new variation here now here this is a
kind of an interesting moment for black
because now with the bishop already on
c5 hmm I start to have a quick think for
just a quick second because I'm starting
to to like something that's actually
funny a moment ago I shoot away the idea
and said that Queen h4 wasn't that good
now however with the bishop on c4 in the
Bishop on c5 the idea of Queen h4 starts
to be a little bit more attractive but
now I have to think okay not a hundred
percent sure in this case after Bishop
c4 right away let me just think about
this a bit I got some ideas that I'm
thinking several ideas I'm thinking that
you could play Queen f6 to put pressure
on d4 you could play Knight f6 hitting
this pawn on e4
what other attractive possibilities are
there for black I'm not sure okay let's
just pick one okay I'm going to pick
Knight f6 so I'll attack this pawn on e4
I'll induce castling OOP yeah there we
go
castles so we get a position like this
so again from blacks point of view what
black would like to do is either take
the pawn for free thank you very much or
play for d7 d5 it's possible that white
could make a pawn sacrifice with Bishop
g5 h6 Bishop h4 g5 bishop g3
Knight takes e4 but that's something
that white should really you know
prepare for and like you need some with
a computer chess engine used to jet
double-check but my recommendation for
you is to look at the move Bishop before
check provoked c3 then go Bishop c5 you
could save yourself a world of trouble
my pleasure
questions about your openings now is the
time folks come on Frank you haven't
played in ages what was your big Frank
Cammarata from the house of Staunton is
here today from Tennessee you've played
correspondence world chess you played
master level over the board chess what
did you have a problem with when you
were black yeah what would bug you okay
okay okay so you you're a French defense
player
amongst other things and you found the
move Bishop b4 off-putting like you
didn't really like the positions that
came right and that is true that is true
this particular position from whites
point of view it's really really hard to
open the position and in truth the
leverage for opening the position more
often stands with black that is to say
black gets the chance to play f7 f6 this
idea of f4 f5 never really works for for
white so essentially it's blacks choice
to keep this position closed yes
yeah which was interesting big yeah I Oh
in this particular position I always
felt that the strongest move for black
was 97 other people have different ideas
but I always thought that 97 now in this
particular position is white I thought
that white had three three moves only
even though whites played a lot of other
moves one move is what are you going to
do with your bishop your bishop on c1 so
one move that I always pay particular
attention to was a four with the
intention of bringing the bishop out to
a3 the other move that I paid particular
attention to was h4 with the idea of
advancing this pawn as quickly up the
board as I could in other words I didn't
want black to ever really get full
control of this square and once I have
my pawn on h5 I'm not worried about
Knight f5 because I always have g4 so I
always thought there were three primary
moves here h4 h4 a4 Knight f3 is like
the standard move and I never really
liked that for white the other move I
thought that was the most challenging
was Queen g4 what you said is the poison
pawn I never quite thought of the winner
were poison pawn I'm not exactly what
sure what this is called but okay Queen
g4 96 Queen takes from the days of bad
vinick's me Slav and many decades before
and after this has been a crucial
position I always thought that this
position was actually favorable for
white and the reason was was I thought
that this move Knight f3 was best I
think that they played 92 Queen c7 f4
takes Queen here and this position has
been played countless times so this is
like the standard position I think for
the better part of decades everybody and
his brother was playing Bishop d7
I like Queen takes c3 they played
castles I like Bishop d2 and I like
white okay I like white and I remember
getting into a hoary public battle in
the pages of inside chess with none
other than John Watson International
Master John Watson who was a very big
supporter of the French defense he said
how you know like how dare you
transgress and suggest for a moment that
blacks position is worse and blah blah
blah blah now today what is very
extraordinary is everybody agrees with
me that Queen takes c3 leads to an
advantage for white the move that
everybody seems to be playing including
Ghouta gata Kamsky and others is this
move and like at the time that I was
studying this particular line at the
winner were d4 nobody played d4 like
well what's that well the idea is as
gross as it is is that after you Trey
Trey Trey tree trade I think they go
here here here
Black's idea is basically as simple as
he wants to castle sometimes simply at
the cost of this pawn on a7 he wants to
play Bishop g2 and is piece of stand
really really powerfully okay and a lot
of grandmasters are having trouble with
d4 in this in this line at the winner
work and I don't know what'd be
up-to-date latest and greatest is I just
know that when I was studying this line
for white and black I liked White's
position after Bishop d7 Queen takes c3
and I don't know what to make of d4
today so I'd have to give that a rethink
it is and nobody played at the time I
was studying it I mean it was logical
only in the sense that it depends upon
on c3 but
aha
well here again there are many
approaches that white could take okay so
for example taking this pawn sure looks
a tractive I have seen guys go nuts here
with the very barbaric h4 so the very
barbaric idea is just as it looks
the idea is to run this pawn as fast as
possible to h7 okay so why would we want
let's just throw a move in here for
white
ephra black I'm not saying this is the
best move or anything like that I'm just
so I can give you an idea and enable
illustration rather of what's in whites
intent is is by putting the pawn on h7
as fast as possible you draw the rook to
h8 so you get to play g4 once the pawn
gets to g4 there's no there's no funny
business with a knight coming at 593 and
once the pawn gets to g4 you've got this
very nice diagonal that you can sit upon
it doesn't necessarily like guarantee
white an advantage or something like
that I'm just saying that there are
other possibilities for white then
capturing the pawn on d4 to my mind I
don't like that fun on d4 I wanted to
capture it you know they could take as
many many of blacks units off the board
as I could so I mean I again I'd have to
just check what the the games are what
the current valuation but the winner
were still remains a problem for white
you're right alright
oh yes oh yes oh yes I guess we have
looked at a numerous rook takes III
sacrifices I'm showing the pin variation
not too long ago where I saying well in
the pin variation the Sicilian you're
not giving up an exchange you're just
doubling White's prawns and it's sort of
like saying hey you know prove through
the pawns aren't we all right ah let me
see here
next question please yes yeah yeah well
indeed I I love playing the over Bach
variation against the Kings Indian
essentially today the Kings Indian has
been kind of like this resilient
creature that everybody's been trying to
kill and then you know throwing all
kinds of new ideas against the Kings
Indian by the way I should say that this
is not at abia position Knight f3 but I
noticed that a lot of players from Levon
Aronian and others are experimenting
with a very early h3 so it's not like
the same ish they want to play h3 Bishop
e3 and sometimes put their knight on f3
white is doing all kinds of things and
black is doing all kinds of things one
of my favorites was Bishop e2 castles
and now we have the basic tabby a
position for what is called the over box
system yuryev Urbach grandmaster from
the soviet union now Russia when was
long lived grandmasters I think URI is
one of the oldest these up there in his
90s he championed this system it bears
his name
a very popular system with me when in in
the youth of my career I like this very
much because it just seemed to me that
it took a lot of the sting
if you will out of the Kings Indian and
even the kid in a proper Kings Indian
after the movie 5d five black is forever
aspiring to play f5 and it just seemed
to me that the move Bishop g5 interfered
threw a spanner in those ideas and if
black ever played h6 I was really happy
because after I would retreat with my
Bishop to e3 I'd end up picking up a
tempo with Queen d2 provoking the move
King h7 and as every Kings Indian
defense player knows that when you're
playing for a 5 + f5 your King doesn't
belong on h7 so I was doing horrible
things to the world of chess with my
trusty overbook and I ran into a guy his
name was Boris Gelfand
and Boris in those days took a very very
innovative approach to this position
that nobody had ever played against me I
had a ton of games that went c5 d5 and
it ended up looking like a Benoni type
of position and I enjoyed playing those
positions for white I had a ton of
opponents play e5 d5 against me getting
into those Kings Indian where this pin
somehow really throws black off of his
game and I just had a tremendous success
record
so what Gelfand did he took the very
novel approach against me he played c7
c6 looks like a simple non-committal
move yeah
yes 'if i d5 pawn takes pawn takes Queen
takes rook takes 95 advice if I did it
in the wrong way am I supposed to play
h7 h6 first or something I sure hope I
haven't done it in the wrong way because
here I may simply be losing material so
I must be thinking of h6 first yeah I'm
sorry I think I'm sure I'm thinking of
h6 of my game with Bala shop where Bala
shot played h6 Bishop e3 e5 d5 first I
apologize
what I what I did happen pardon me
nope see where is it there c6 I played
Queen d2 okay so please I'm thinking to
myself please play e5 and I can get into
the cut I want to play e5 d5 and get
into the kinds of Kings Indian defense
positions where my bishop on g5 is
simply more than annoying Kelvin played
Knight a six against me and this was a
real conundrum it's sort of like says to
white okay what are you going to play if
you play
Knight f3 then you can get into lines of
play that is simply transpositional that
are not unique to the offer bak and in
the augur box system often times white
once in some cases to be able to play g4
right in this in those cases where a
five d5 gets shut down you want to play
g4 in other cases you want to play f4 so
I thought this was an opportunity to
play f4
or night here night here night here how
weird is that how many kings Indians
have you ever seen where blacks night
gets onto the e6 square man zero so this
was quite a unique approach by Boris
Gelfand and I really admired him for it
I think I played Bishop g5 to h4
and he played bishop here like now I was
completely uh you know bamboozled there
were reasons that I didn't want to play
g3
what were those reasons now I have to
remember I'm I don't think I wanted to
play g3 because of d5 and suddenly this
night on e6 attacks my pawn on d4 and
makes it impossible for me to play
Knight takes e4 so this was a very very
very different type of approach by black
to the offer boxes 'dom it gave me fits
long story short I ended up losing the
game with white and this idea of c6 96
97 96 made a very powerful impression to
me and when I analyzed it at home I
ended up giving up the offer bug for
this reason as well as my game with
Garry Kasparov to wear her Gary did bad
things to my over Bach opening and I
just thought that this move Knight a
six-night semen even a 6 97 96 really
deserves consideration so that's where I
would recommend you go for salvation
if you get happy over Bach was giving
you problems so c6 Knight a6 what did I
play again
I played f6 because I was just thinking
that in case I play Knight f3 now e 5
now he 5 gets me to a position where I'm
not happy with the fact that I don't
have these ideas of f3 and g4 and blacks
doing quite ok they may be even very
well in this footage with B for now I
think e 4 is hanging well there is an
issue I think it's hanging here here I'm
well I'm threatening Knight takes after
Bishop e7 let's say let's say here
Bishop takes d6 let's say I'm not well
yeah why not just take this guy Knight
takes f3 check you probably have to take
with the pawn if we take with the bishop
you got to be careful about yeah yeah by
being exposed
so it takes takes takes I'm assuming
takes this looks pretty reasonable for
black you still have efore to you got it
yeah you Willie yeah you got this double
threat so black is threatening to take
and take advantage of the pen as well as
this very annoying issue true yeah any
may yeah I think it I think it's more
like the other but in any case
regardless of whether white is managing
to save his position or not suddenly
somehow the initiative shifted right
that this is a position that I wouldn't
necessarily embrace
as white probably something like Bishop
f5 intending rook c8 there's a little
bit unpleasant for the first player to
play in any case one things for one
thing's for sure Kings Indian defense
players can rejoice they got that
beautiful vish upon g7 parney this guy
on the un'ytu yeah yeah small little
detail anyway that was the thing that
put me off of the other bat just
something to put in your cap and stew
over put it in your chest engine half
fun when you have a lazy afternoon c6 96
97 96 oh absolutely the King's gambit
again arguably the oldest opening yeah
well one of the one of the fellows who
was really trying his best to champion
the cause of the Kings gambit was
manager short Nigel short was playing it
off and on there's always periods of
excitement somebody comes up with some
new idea and it suddenly has a burst of
popularity and then it kind of dies off
in fashion well a number of the sharpest
lines the Kings gambit have been
analyzed two draws okay so that's
already one thing that white finds very
off-putting is that if black knows what
he's doing and he plays in the sharpest
possible way the game is probably a draw
but to me and a defense I've always
championed when I'm black I like playing
against the King's gambit is to accept
the gambit now basically there are moves
there are moves like Bishop c4 here
there are moves like d4 here but by far
the the most often played move is Knight
f3 because black is facing this
potentially disruptive Czech black is
threatened to make this potentially
disruptive check and I remember you know
like I think it was Jeffrey Jeffrey
Parsons had loaned me one of his books
and Steinitz
of all people played the move b3 here
with white and you go holy cow oh well I
loved the idea of b3 well the idea of b3
and I'm not going to challenge you guys
to guess because that will just put you
you'll give up chest is to put the King
on b2 Stein is his idea is to put the
King on b2 yeah so the idea was that
after check King here d5 Knight f3
Bishop g4 takes this pawn what Steinitz
wants to do is go King here King here
and King here okay I don't recommend
that you do this at home maybe if your
Stein is but the point is is that white
does and has entertained other moves
Bishop c4 is one move d4 is another but
by far the most popular is Knight f3
okay so this is our main line now here
lots of choices Bobby Fischer wrote a
book a bus to the Kings gambit and
played the move d7 d6 many theory books
have recommended h6 other people like
Mickey Adams is a big champion of D
fight here I don't play any of those
this is so easy to learn it's banal
you play g5 you just play g5 okay now
essentially in this position if it's
black to move black plays Bishop g7 d6
h6 plays like Bobby Fischer recommended
in his guide to a bus to the Kings
gambit and white is busted in this
position it's been long established that
the only move to even try to equalize
huh for white is to play h4 okay any
move other than the move h4 and he fails
to equalize okay so he has to play h4
but here's a question does he get an
advantage after h4 okay
black is obliged to play g4 white plays
Knight here now it's obvious and very
easy if that if white is allowed to play
moves like d4 Bishop takes f4 Knight
takes d4 well black and resign okay so
black plays d7 d6 attacking the knight
there's no choice black white has to
take this pawn and after Knight takes d4
the best move is Knight f6 okay so here
white is facing a very clear choice
should he trade or play Knight f2 now
essentially the theoreticians have said
well after Knight f6 black gets the
better game white has to play Knight f2
okay I mean just check the databases
okay so here after Knight f2 we pause
and we just go okay one two three one
two three black to move on the other
hand if white is able to play f4 and
Bishop takes a deform Bishop takes f4
White has perfect resign you just lose
so very very key move here for black is
rook g8 very important move this really
messes white up because it ties the
bishop to the f1 square anchors the pawn
on g2 and with the mover up g8 it also
creates a very very powerful incentive
for white to move his King Queen side in
other words after rook g8 you really
don't want to Castle short you're not
happy about that decision
so rook g8 d for these moves have been
played many times bishop D for Bishop 8
D for Bishop h6 Knight c3 Knight c6
okay knight c6 now we start to get to a
critical position white to move white to
move okay as we look at the position we
start to understand that this pawn on d4
is really requiring the services of the
Queen okay
you start thinking to yourself I as
white I want to exit stage left
so I've got to make a move like Queen to
d3 Bishop to d2 castles and if I can
execute all of those moves well Black
has issues one move that you really
really really want to avoid is d5 after
d5 95 the Knights terrific it's just to
this fantastic block hater in the center
of the board and white is going to have
a massive number of problems so
everybody played Queen b3 now back in
the early 80s when I was looking at the
stuff oops this was the main line and
here there was a line of play that I
really wanted to do for black check this
out
I wanted to play rook g3 nobody ever
allowed me to do this
nobody ever allowed me to do rook g3
okay so white clearly has to defend his
pawn on d4 he's got to play Queen c4 now
I really wanted to play Bishop e6 he
bring out the pieces you know go-go-go
right so uh what could white do I mean
he's almost obliged to play d5 I mean
because you know it's tough otherwise
okay so d5 Knight e5
I thought Queen b5 check I thought this
ship here
I thought Queen takes now here I've
sacrificed upon but I was absolutely
convinced that black stood better now
this is kind of like home analysis and
stuff like that again I never got a
chance to use it in practice in in a
real game but my attitude was you know a
lot of white pieces are passive I really
like this harmonious development of my
Knight okay I've sacrificed a pawn it's
funny my King may not look good it's
certainly not castling short is not
castling long but I thought that King f8
really put the onus on white like white
does not want to make the move Bishop d2
because after rook b8 he's giving up
this pawn
b2 and whites King still hasn't found
sanctuary
if white Mook makes a move for example
like Queen a6 well I've got ideas like
this night coming to g4 after trades
nights coming to e3 I've also got ideas
again after Queen a6 ideas like Queen e8
putting pressure I think I actually saw
some light it went ok hold on no this
was a no this was a stupid idea I
apologize this came from a stupid move
like night here greedy just stupid
stupid greed so the idea of the stupid
greed was that when the knight jumps to
b5 and that was the reason for my King
e8 I was getting out of this one with
check this night on b5 gave up
protection of the e4 square and I was
attracted to this light check which is
why I put my rook on g3 in the first
place because after Bishop takes pawn
takes my idea with black is as soon as
this Knight move from f2 I wanted to
play Knight takes e4 and have some fun
you know let's rock and roll
and so this is my recommended line - you
can that in case your opponent's come up
with the Kings gambit and this or
another game you take it Knight f3 you
go g5 you go for g4 you force the knight
to move to e5 you play d6 you for some
Knight to capture Knight f6 and this
star move rook g8 I know and this other
kind of funny-looking move Bishop h6 but
it's necessary it's vitally important
for you to maintain the pawn on f4 after
Knight c3
knight c6 this move rook g3 that's just
already by the way a lot of the people
who play the Kings gambit their attitude
is look I'm playing this gambit to take
the initiative and I want to blast you
off the board and you're coming out with
moves like rook g3 and Bishop e6